all right my next guest is the founding
director of the Yale Gryphon Prevention
Research Center who recently volunteered
his time fighting Koba 19 at a hospital
emergency department in the Bronx
please welcome dr. David Katz doctor
thank you for being here thank you your
credentials for talking about this are
impeccable I know you were at the
Einstein College of Medicine you got
your degree the Yale School of Public
Health nobody questions your credentials
they did some some people questioned
your op-ed that was in the New York
Times about a month ago it was called is
our fight against corona worse than the
disease I think it's good someone's at
least asking that question we can't just
lapse into groupthink
let me quote the thing you said recently
that I think is most interesting and
gets at this point you said if all we do
is flatten the curve you don't prevent
deaths you just change the dates explain
that yeah and and Bill first of all
again thank you great to be with you I
that's taken directly from some of the
world-class risk modelers that I've been
working with since that op-ed in the New
York Times so I wrote my bed Tom
Friedman wrote a column channeling mine
ran it up a high flagpole and then a
who's who in public health and economics
found me and we've been working together
ever since and so some of these risk
models basically show essentially what
flattening the curve does is keeps
people away from one another and away
from the virus so the virus doesn't
spread but you also don't cultivate any
immunity if you do a really effective
job of locking everybody in place and
preventing viral transmission there's
still some low-level potential for viral
exposure out in the world but very few
of us get that exposure the minute you
release those clamps and let people back
into the world we're all vulnerable so
most of the models suggest that
flattening the curve makes sense in
Phase one so you don't overwhelm medical
systems for example but you've got to
have a Phase two if you don't transition
to a Phase two
whenever you release the clamps the
virus is out in the world waiting for
you everybody is vulnerable and that big
peak in case isn't that big peak in
deaths that you were trying to avoid
really just happens at a later date
so you would be suggesting something
more like what Sweden is doing Sweden we
know has kept open at schools you can go
to a bar you can go to a restaurant and
get your haircut
they haven't had numbers that are that
different from countries that have
locked down how do you sum up that yeah
so so let me start bill by saying
essentially what I reject because I
think we're very polarized society I
think the way media hype things up
actually amplifies the extremes so one
extreme we've got the you know lock
everything down hunker in a bunker until
a there's a vaccine 18 months or years
or whenever be forever or see you die of
something else whichever comes first
that that's just horrible it's it's
inhumane makes no sense but at the other
extreme we've got the liberate blank
fill in the name of the state which is
basically you know everybody in the
water including Grandma and nevermind
the riptides and the sharks and you know
every man from self that's also absurd
so in the middle what you do is you
identify who is at risk of a severe case
of this infection and who's not who is
at risk of dying of this at a you know
at a pretty high frequency and who is it
extremely low risk so this is just like
risks we take every day yeah some young
people will die of this but sadly
tragically some young people die
crossing the street or in a car crash
every day there are risks we willingly
take on every day Sweden's approach is a
little too close to the everybody in the
water don't worry about the Riptide end
of the spectrum for my taste I think we
can do them better we can kind of look
around the world and say okay if you
don't lock this down at all if you don't
protect the vulnerable mortality in
Sweden does look to me to be higher not
massively higher than everyplace else
but higher why put those lives at risk
on the other hand if you lock everything
down you destroy livelihoods you destroy
jobs and and what I was saying in what I
didn't really think was a controversial
at the beginning is there's really more
than one way built for this situation to
hurt people or even kill them and all of
them are bad and there's more than one
way to protect people and save them and
all of those are good so one thing we
want to do is keep those vulnerable to
severe infection away from this nasty
bug but we don't want to destroy
people's lives and livelihoods and means
of feeding their families and and
interestingly you know I am just back
from three days in an emergency
department in the Bronx where I was
volunteering as a physician to support
my my colleagues who I applaud you know
they've been in there from the beginning
they'll be there through the end but but
this is exactly the view that prevails
there you know there might be the notion
that we'll the frontline people they're
much more concerned about staying away
from the virus than they are about you
know can we open society up not true
their parents you know I was talking to
my colleagues and say I'm really
struggling to balance my clinical duties
with home schooling my kids and then you
know think of a scenario like like this
dad is a nurse
mom's a paramedic they've got two kids
at home and there's no school no daycare
no nannies no all pairs nothing for them
to do one of these frontline people who
really wants to be in the battle has to
stay home to take care of the kids and
they're really torn so there's a middle
path and the middle path essentially is
high risk people are protected from
exposure low risk people go out in the
world early and and here's here's the
odd part bill that I think people have a
hard time confronting and accepting we
actually kind of want to get this and
get it over with and be immune because
that is the path to the all-clear that
doesn't require us to make wait for a
vaccine which optimistically is 18
months away but could be much longer
yeah I think you make a lot of sense
there and I think it's a shame you're
talking about politicization but people
like you who sound reasonable maybe it's
not the exact one true opinion you hear
somewhere else has to go on Fox News say
you know you're not a Fox News guy I'm
not a fox news guy but you know on the
other hand I am a bridges not Bunker's
right and you know it doesn't
really helped the world if all we ever
do is talk to other people who already
own our opinions it was interesting I
really debated you know do I go on fox
news do I not that's not my usual crowd
but the simple fact is we should come
together in common cause on common
ground maybe there's a real opportunity
here for an aha American moment that's
between the extremes of left and right
where we all say yeah actually we want
to save as many lives as possible and
you know one of the interesting things
bill is it's sort of the the left side
of the spectrum that the liberal
ideology that seems to be so resistant
to talking at all about unemployment and
the economy but that's the very same
camp that tends to appreciate that the
single leading driver of bad health
outcomes is poverty social determinants
of health are massively important so you
know frankly 30 million people
unemployed that falls disproportionately
hard on the people who can least bear
the unemployment right for at most risk
of food insecurity we're at reduced risk
of depression addiction all of that's
important too so maybe there's a real
opportunity here to say hey there's a
middle path we've been neglecting it
it's the way through this thing and it
leads to total harm minimization we want
to minimize deaths and severe cases of
the infection we also want to minimize
the fallout the health fallout of
societal collapse and economic ruin yeah
I think philosophically America got too
used to the idea of win wins and they
need to get used to the idea of
lose-lose that's more what life is like
sometimes lose lose there's no good
choice this year there's only one least
bad choice and yeah I think when you
talk about the fact that we have this
president who is so inept to dealing
with this but he's not going away he's
not going away
he is the president he's going to be
there let me ask you this about testing
it doesn't look like we're gonna have
testing for a long time so look in the
war movies when they said to the pilot
you know your equipment is out he says I
know but we're gonna have to fly blind
on this one is that this kind of
situation we just gonna have to say the
least hard
choice is at some point we might have to
do this without the testing the people
who say we can't open up the economy
until we have the testing well that
can't go on for a year and we might not
have the testing till then at the right
regard so a few things so you said it's
not win-win it's lose-lose in a sense
and in public health we talk about harm
reduction you know so for example a
needle exchange program that says we
can't get everybody to stop using
intravenous drugs but we can give them
clean needles so they don't get HIV for
example that's harm reduction and so
when you're in a lose-lose scenario you
look to minimize harm
maybe you can't maximize benefit but you
can minimize harm so from the beginning
we've been posting materials my
colleagues and I under the rubric total
harm minimization that's what we want to
achieve here yeah listen you know a
historic pandemic is a bad situation a
historic pandemic with a fairly you know
inept group of federal leaders is an
even worse situation you know if only we
had grown-ups in charge but on the
testing front we're making a mistake
there bill because we do have testing
it's not great by the way you know so
one day one of these 12-hour shifts in
the emergency room in the Bronx we
admitted maybe 20 people we were sure
had Kovac you know there was just no
doubt about it they absolutely possibly
had Kovac and either 19 or 20 of them
tested negative so that the testings not
great and the the false negative rate is
high but some of the test kits work
pretty well they're certainly better
than nothing and here's the thing what
we aren't going to have anytime soon is
the capacity to test the whole
population but we deal with that all the
time
the CDC routinely does what's called
representative random sampling where
they randomly select people and make
sure that they traverse the gamut of age
and socioeconomics and zip code and
health status and then you extrapolate
the whole population we could do that
with 10,000 people and we have the test
case for that so we really need
grown-ups in charge we need federal
oversight we need a commitment to
getting the critical data and frankly
that could happen fast it's the work of
72 hours
in the absence of that we're turning to
States
so for example we just heard there's
widespread testing in New York I think
Governor Cuomo is doing a great job
there and it looks like at least 20% of
the population of New York may have
antibodies well that's close to four
million people and what that means is
the death toll in New York tragic though
it is and you know again all these
deaths are real people and my
condolences to the families but just
looking at the statistics for a minute
20,000 deaths out of four million people
that's half a percent you know we're
starting to see that the mortality toll
of this when you get the denominator is
really small and I think the
denominators even bigger than that so
we're not totally blind yeah I think we
do have to fly in a bit of a fog but
we're not flying totally blind okay I
worry when I hear people talk about how
we deal with this that they leave out
the immune system I mean obviously we
know that that's a big part of it but I
feel like that gets such short shrift
and I worry that the country is going to
think that the way to deal with microbes
in the future is to lock yourself away
and it cannot be that Germans are
ubiquitous they are everywhere you can't
avoid them you have to win the battle
inside you wrote a book recently called
how to eat which is a been a pet theme
of mine since I've been on television
that the main thing about our health is
what we eat and you write 80 percent of
all chronic disease and premature death
is preventable
using lifestyle as a medicine yes stop
shaking hands but you can't avoid germs
they're everywhere
yeah it's a great point and integrate
segue so first of all I just want people
to understand again I'm a physician I do
public health I'm trained in
epidemiology it really still looks to me
as it did that month ago when I wrote my
piece for the New York Times 98 to 99
percent of the cases of this infection
are mild most people don't even seem to
know they have it
and that this is true even in the
emergency department a small portion of
the cases are potentially severe and
that's what makes your points so
important in your bill the severe cases
occur in people who are old and people
who are sick now those two things go
together
but sadly in America they also splay
apart there
a lot of young people with coronary
disease obesity type 2 diabetes
hypertension and by and large those are
diseases of lifestyle I'm a past
president of the American College of
lifestyle medicine that's what we
advocate lifestyle is medicine because
it can fix all of that here's the
interesting bit the stuff we can't sell
to people eat well exercise don't smoke
don't drink excessively get enough sleep
manage your stress because it's such
potent medicine we can't sell it because
the timeline for harm is too long you
know essentially heart disease stops you
in slow motion type 2 diabetes stocks
and slow motion and our DNA is wired to
fight-or-flight you know if it's not
coming at me in minutes or days I'm sort
of blind to it welco vyd is coming at
you in minutes and days and everybody is
alarmed and all the same things are risk
factors so essentially what this
pandemic has done has turned America's
chronic health liabilities into an acute
threat and there is an opportunity a
crisis of interest opportunity the very
things that we're always telling people
to do to promote their long-term health
actually do fortify your immunity
against this virus if you start eating
optimally start fitting physical
activity into your in place routes now
if you get enough sleep that can affect
how your immune system functions in
hours certainly in days and a whole lot
in a span and of weeks there's a better
time for America to get healthy if I
were one of the grown-ups in charge of
this mess I would have a national health
promotion campaign as part of what we do
in an organized way look we're all
social distancing sheltering in place
let's make lemonade from the lemons
let's turn this into an opportunity of
healthy it will protect you in the short
run it'll help protect your loved ones
and when this is over we'll be a
healthier nation into the bargain
great point I really appreciate you
doing this I think you make a lot of
sense I hope I see you somewhere other
than Fox News because I don't like to
watch it alright thank you I'm gonna be
on your show bill so I'm beyond it again
hopefully in person all right take care
you too stay well
you